hey 42 here Walmart is the largest
company in the world I'm the biggest
employer in the u.s. pulling in 469
billion dollars in revenue every year
out of the top seven revenue generating
companies in the world Walmart is the
only one that doesn't deal in oil and
gas in fact every year everyone in the
world will make an average of 1.1
purchases at a Walmart store Walmart has
two point 1 million full-time employees
that 7 times the population of Iceland
in 2012 Walmart registered approximately
four hundred and forty four billion
dollars in sales which is 20 billion
more than Austria's GDP if Walmart were
a country it would be the 26th largest
economy in the world if Walmart was an
army it would have the second largest
military in the world
behind China Walmart is bigger than Home
Depot target Sears and Costco combined
in 2009 Walmart sold more bananas than
any other item if Walmart's more than
900 million square feet of retail space
were spread out over one place it would
take up roughly 34 miles which is about
1.5 times the size of Manhattan Walmart
parking lots alone take up roughly the
size of Tampa Florida in 2000 Walmart
was sued 4851 times or about once every
two hours ninety percent of all
Americans live within 15 miles of a
Walmart the most frequent destination
typed into TeleNav GPS devices is
Walmart roughly 4,700 about 90 percent
of international stores operate under a
banner other than Walmart including Asda
in the UK say you in Japan and best
price in India all of which are part of
the massive Walmart family
an additional Walmart Supercenter per
100,000 residents increases average BMI
by 0.25 units under the obesity rate by
2.4 percent 8 cents for every US dollar
is spent at Walmart on average about 200
stores go out of business in the area
surrounding a town with a new Walmart
store Walmart CEO Mike Duke make sure
his employees are paid but that doesn't
mean he doesn't keep some for himself in
2010 his 35 million dollar salary caused
him to earn more in just one hour than
the average Walmart employee makes in a
full year thanks for the view subscribe
for more 42